okay four people joining a live stream
this is about new features in Wolfram
language now post version 12 because
version 12 is wrapped up and hopefully
coming out very soon actually hopefully
coming out next Tuesday there so um so
in the agenda we have three
documentation things and then four new
functions okay so there is some wording
on on a couple of tables that have
looked you by the way I did do I need to
update or is this is this very recently
updated or is this some jobs dated in
the previous meeting so that's okay I
just the axiomatic theory
why is this experimental well we decided
ethics as axiomatic theory itself
experimental sorry I met okay yeah so so
their first two tables are about the
entities we with theories we support and
and yes I wanted you to look at what I
wrote and and the editor was also
pointing out the same thing I don't
believe in this I'm sorry you know the
fact boy see I mean the fact is an axiom
system is just an axiom system the fact
that it has a model in terms of some
particular operator it's just an
interpretation said I'm saying yes but
we are offering the axioms in a very
definite way for example we now depend
on the fact that this equation our logic
and so and that limits us in what we can
express at the moment yeah when are we
going to get what I don't know what's
happened to the whole um what's happened
to the resolution theorem proving stuff
by the way this isn't Otto
incorrectly see that it's not all yeah
yeah all there's no tagging there yeah
that's why okay so this isn't using NAND
this is using dot yes because we will
place an and by dot so if you do action
Matic theory what from axioms come
operators I see that's the NAND like
operator exactly which the use of
country place by whatever they want boy
I mean I have to say I I mean that's a
discovery interface that we even
mentioned that discovery interface
what do you mean the the axiomatic
theory open closed in the examples we
shouldn't do it just in the examples if
it's if it's real we should do it in the
end the main documentation ok we can add
them yeah I mean if we really think this
is the right way to do it to have the
open closed gives a list of supported
axiom I'm not wild about that in a lot
of Pacolet pages we only document it as
a note rather than in the main usage you
know and and there are inconsistencies
like some use and in some of them open
bracket you know open closed bracket is
the same thing as all the symbol all and
then others they're different and so and
I don't know if axiomatic theory
supports the all it doesn't okay
okay I'm not thrilled about that I mean
personally I think the better approach
to this would be to treat these things
more like we treat well now how do we do
what is the discovery interface for
things like named classifiers I mean
there's a whole bunch of cases where we
have essentially um see I mean okay what
I had originally thought we would do
here is to have a repository for these
then every one of those axiom systems
would get its own documentation page
which I don't think would be bad mmm yes
but thisis what we've followed from some
time ago
this is written because at some point
you requested that we write the table of
all systems we support currently yeah
and it just what didn't know exactly
what to write on there again the way
that supports the following properties
we should have that first okay okay
then we have a group dedicated to
boolean algebra and then the rest
dedicated to algebraic series there's a
very noise and you know that that's I
think it's Jose actually well I was
going to comment the the the tagging in
that notebook is wrong because those
properties are being tagged as for the
first argument so that's why so what was
that the right it should be tagged as
for the second argument right so if you
try to type in you know one of those in
the second ones should be put tagged for
the first argument right correct
yeah okay all right so let's look at
these supports the following theories
for boolean algebra supports
you
supports the following and including
sounds weird no that's wrong
I did not like mr. McCune
you
but we're being very nice
you
um
you
perhaps with a need to specify the
operators in the boolean algebra section
I think that's right but if we're going
to do that
you
you
we could say paren six axioms
you
you
um six standard axioms then we just say
operators bla bla bla
so make some sense and then just say
operator and that makes sense to me
um
[Music]
you shouldn't say explicitly commutative
well okay you can handle the rest of
this okay what is happening to us adding
additional axiomatic theories so John is
looking into this so the thing is that
as I said because right now we depend on
a question our theory we cannot add more
than many more than these because
lattice theory and all kinds of other
random things yes yes and and via lean
or other solvers we will be able to
handle first order theory in general
okay um I'm adding
if we don't get to this any other time
this is a good summer school project for
somebody
axiomatic theories to this because I
mean you know lattice Theory ring theory
all these kinds of things where we got
rings there we don't have lattices we
don't have you know squads or whatever
they're called there's a whole bunch of
other ones yes but something like fields
is not described evolving in equation or
logic I understand that I understand so
we need to get that and okay did what
happened to our temporal logic effort
well we have a meeting and we I think
that meeting we discover that your view
of temporal logic is wider than what we
were doing yes so yeah so we are now
restarting working on any on our
projects related to time and time
description Exeter right okay so that's
a post twelve oh thing and that's very
good yeah
I hope we're gonna get trees as well yes
I have to talk with Tony and and he has
always things to do yeah we should work
that for the hoi polloi
what's temporal logic it's logical you
talk about time like you say like it has
you know for for the whole future and
you can ask questions like well can you
give a good example Jose yeah so it's an
extension of propositional logic in
which you have operators like until and
[Music]
yes and you can include comparisons of
time moments okay so truth values depend
on time and so something can be true for
this period of time and then Falls right
and what's tricky is things like things
that last a week and start sometime in
the future how do they overlap with
something are they before
something which does this and that the
other that's where it gets kind of
tricky and what happens if the two
events are spaced like related
well there's yes relativistic temporal
logic is a whole different thing and
general relativistic temporal logic
probably has never been thought about I
mean that's absolutely ornate I have no
idea okay but all right it just didn't
occur to me that temporal actually meant
temporal but now I understand yes as
opposed to spiritual or something like
that right
the fair enough call on the live stream
is asking about when the axiomatic
theory yes it's in twelve oh this stuff
is all in twelve oh um okay we on to the
next thing so so yes III do I'm sorry I
want to come back to this thing I would
like to see us make this a lightweight
repository or alternatively possibly at
least have those things be documentation
pages
right so we've got plenty of custom
documentation pages that are you know
what I'm saying where we have a list of
things but then each one of the string
names is its own special documentation
page type
okay I mean I'm not sure how important
that is for these but I mean it doesn't
really matter unless we get a lot more
theories and I mean the total number of
theories in the world may not be that
large yet you know it's part of it by
the way you have a lot of background
noise I don't know what you sound like
you're in a convertible car or something
I'm sorry I mean I know somebody's in
the kitchen with their microwave diner
no it's not what it is it's it's some
it's some problem with some wind noise I
don't know what that is weird okay let's
look at this oh boy what is all this no
this is simpler than it looks so Carlos
suggested that we document the moon Kiev
case of the by functions in the
definition boxes so so I just separated
the various cases we have
yes I think it would be a good example
of you go to one of them so you see that
there for example in the second line we
have the multi F no in other cases we
have it in nodes in other cases we don't
have it cetera so yeah this is a matter
of just deciding whether we want the
consistency of always having a multi of
case I would say yes on consistency but
right I mean the reason we haven't done
it yet see
so in this case it's not even in the
notes well is it is it implemented it is
implemented yes in that case so that
that's why they send separate section
called not implement it yeah I see so
that so this will be ordering by of list
comma F 1 2 3 comma dot dot does
whatever
um I can do that I just wanted to know
whether you agree on doing that I think
so but I wouldn't put it necessarily
front and center in some of these things
I mean use your judgment because some of
these may be I mean these are fairly
obscure functions key sort by an
ordering by yeah it's probably okay but
but just be careful that you're not
muddying up something which is otherwise
a fairly simple function with some very
complicated thing in the definition box
okay but I think to me it seems
reasonable
um okay some questions on the live
stream um will be cool to have some kind
of repository framework that handles
basic repository infrastructure that is
exactly what we have that is exactly
what the resource system is and that's
that's what resource object is all about
everything is is based on resource
object where is that okay yeah so that's
exactly what we have unfortunately every
single repository whether it's the
function repository the neural net
repository each one of these has
different pieces of the resource object
bit different things in its resource
objects but they're all handled in the
unified way and underneath the ability
for users to stand up their own
repositories is something that hopefully
we will be getting to but we still have
some more examples to build out we've
never had a purely cookie cutter very
simple repository everyone has had its
own special features of you know like
the neural net repository has to have
special stuff for training evaluation
networks was training networks and so on
when is the cloud being a valid being
updated to version 12 now it's a funny
thing you asked that because the answer
is
[Music]
anybody remember what the answer is from
this morning's meeting I think sometime
this week that's what I think too
I think I think like to maybe write
isn't it today
I think it's today last I heard I wasn't
in this morning's meeting but last I
heard it was today they suppose I can
probably do a really quick check well
I'm trying to go there and it's not even
connecting which is super upsetting
that's really weird maybe maybe it's
updating right now this is why you can't
connect it's really bad that I can't
connect what's going on network is
unreachable so oh my gosh how could that
possibly be well we're all on the
effectively on the internal network oh
my gosh that possibly be let me
disconnect and so I'm logging in from a
that's apparently some some network
issue here so who knows it'll hopefully
get resolved quickly um okay let's
continue here document document addition
of key value pairs to Association yes
this is another pair of suggestions this
one from from Roman he wanted to mention
you note that these actual operation
creates a new Association definitely we
should say that and then yes I think it
was you who suggested that these ways of
adding new keys new purse key values to
Association should be documented what is
this to it that it's dropping the
duplicate key right and it's effectively
flattening an association I didn't know
that worked
I don't know that worked at all it can
be any cut the the arguments to an
association can be any combination of
rules list of rules and Association I
didn't know that it's very useful okay
great yeah we should document that why
don't you propose documentation for that
okay so now we have their four new
things so this is a suggestion from view
and there is a meta question here
important for ISD which is how do we
decide in the future when a function
should be for ILD or or from functional
positioning that is a really good
question
and I don't know the answer yet I mean
look let's look at the history okay the
history is things got put in standard
packages and they sat there for decades
and some things in standard packages
were widely used and while nobody like
myself really liked using stuff from
standard packages one did it from time
to time now the function repository I
just don't know how that's going to
evolve whether whether it's going to be
oh you know it's a specialized thing so
it's from the function repository and
that's okay or whether one's always
going to be a little nervous if it's
from the function repository I I don't
think one is gonna be that nervous I
think it's going to be quite um oh boy
we're not even connecting to that Wow
Wow
okay well so much for the function
repository um so because this was a
function with a simple implementation I
was wondering whether this would be a
relatively clear case for
okay so I think I think I agree with you
we'll have to go through a collection of
functions and then decide which ones we
decide to send to there or from
repository and which one is research
research here I I think that what's
gonna happen is we're gonna put them in
the repository they're gonna sit there
they can have some design changes
they're gonna be put in in in the system
you know some fraction are gonna go into
the system I see and I think that which
is a little bit similar to what happen
with standard packages but I think I
mean the bad case there is that there's
a function in the repository I mean
again we can do the same thing I mean we
just put a stripe saying this has been
moved to system and is not necessarily
compatible but you can continue using
the repository version if you want to
right I'm being told that things are
loading right now no they're not loading
for me now
nothing's loading for me um okay so okay
that was that's all I have to say about
that right now I mean if we could look
at the function of buzzer we could
discuss that more clearly I mean I think
it will be useful to go through you know
every month probably and do a survey of
function repository things and say which
things should we consider
as candidates for system functions yes I
see
but I'm we're just not ready for this
yet we don't know right right the
inverse of pluralize yes it has been
suggested that we create a a singular
eyes function but then it happens that
PluralEyes comma one is some sort of
flora singular ization function it is
not documented yes this yeah well I mean
in some languages we'll have things
which are where it's two of something
anybody here know a language where that
happens I mean in Greek ancient Greek
that happened Hebrews in at least four
certain words yeah japanese has a whole
bunch for counting words potentially
okay
well it is a little weird to have
singular eyes be I mean so long as it's
in the documentation for um we don't
even show an example of dogs does it
work if we say plural eyes it doesn't
remove them right now I mean the main
thing right now is the algorithm that I
guess the Conway algorithm they used is
doesn't remove paralyzation and we
talked to the NLP group and they said
you know they can potentially look at
some machine learning options for this
or there's word stemming options you
know word stem on dogs would give you
back dog but it isn't what's them is
cuts off way too much but yeah
logarithmic would stem right yeah so
basically what we need is something
either custom or to cast a wider net for
algorithms to look at for singular eyes
but I think the initial question we had
was would singular eyes be useful as a
standalone function or should it really
just be wrapped up as a an argument form
of chloral eyes right um I think we
should make it work first before we
worry about fishy singular eyes is a
very very weird word
and I don't know what you would call it
I mean um um let's find out if it can
work first I don't think it's the most
important thing in the world I think
it's also actually I I have to say I'm
I'm inclined to add it as one of these
student project ideas um because I think
that um right I'm going to I mean I
think it would be called deep floral
eyes that that's little um that seems
like the most plausible
I just singular eyes it's just the wrong
thing because there's so many other
singularities in this world right yeah
deep really seems like a good movie okay
so I mean if we have something on that I
I think that it's good it's a good
summer school type project it's a good
machine learning project for somebody to
try and it may or may not work with
machine learning um
I assume and I don't know does it work
in languages other than English does
pluralized working language the the
algorithm used for its specific to
English so there's no language option
right now but there certainly should be
that again may be a project for someone
of summer school or someone to spend
more time researching to look at
different pluralization schemes for
their languages
um
okay yeah actually that's a I mean we
should okay um whatever happened to our
inflections thing project inflected
words word inflections project
I know nothing about it who was working
on it but Nick might know about it I
think it's an Alan Joyce project yeah I
don't remember the specifics I mean
they've been various discussions about
you know the different inflected forms
associated with data in the word data or
dictionary yeah I mean the main point is
you've got to be able to say you know
this tense you know the future perfect
of um of Cleve or will have been
cleaving whatever it is whatever the
whatever the right performers yeah
include cuz it's one of the most
irregular verbs in English what is it
what is it some era store it what's it's
some past pod cloven no can't possibly
be cleaved yeah cleave clove cleft
cloven cleavage okay so that that's that
on that so nothing really to do with
this right now except that unfortunately
PluralEyes what is this showing I see
dog comma 1 gives dog but if you start
off with dogs plural
it doesn't deep Lorelei's to dog yeah I
think your allies of comma one simply
gives their the ward itself yes
yeah or when you give up there it gives
the first one and no doubt pluralized
comma zero doesn't say Douglas
[Laughter]
right it should give the form that you
would give for that word being given to
write zero dogs that should actually be
the the correct thing given pluralize
here would be dog yeah I did it did that
actually exactly did that did the right
thing exactly as you say zero dogs
exactly um
right Sandra on a live stream is
commenting that he likes the function
repository and has already contributed
to it which is terrific there's I think
it's I'm very enthusiastic about the
function repository also um let's see
yeah passing quantities to pluralize how
would that work um why would you want to
yes because because well what he means
is no no that's a different thing I mean
if you say two bananas you know like
like for example collective nouns you
know a Parliament of owls right
that is the pluralization okay that this
is doing a different thing that's a
collectivization I mean a an owl the
plural is owls but the collective word
for a collection of owls I believe is a
Parliament of owls if I'm not mistaken
you know a pod of dolphins a school of
fish yes yes I mean that that is an
interesting tagging for a concept is
what the collective word is I actually
think all those collective words as I
recall some random eccentric English guy
just wrote down all of these totally
weird things like Parliament of owls and
somehow they got standardized and they
don't make a lot of sense but but okay
so I mean this is part of you haven't
yet heard it from me but my whole theory
of entity equivalences which is which I
am
developing and there will be a whole
whole discussion about the difference
between a recognized owl and owl as a
concept and owl as a species and so on
um anyway that's that's coming soon I
hope
all right let's keep going symmetric
difference yes so this is a function we
were running to to work on and it has
been suggested by users again that we
add it and so I was right in there they
plan for the design of symmetric
difference following what region
symmetric differences which takes on a
bit many of my livestream call is
pointing out an Irish a bear to be IRT
as to people TR I with an accent on it
you are is three people and so on I see
these are counting words right
I understand it's like a brace of what
is a brace of pheasants anyway is it at
the fixed number of pheasants I don't
know but um the question is when a when
accounting words not disembodied from
what they count in other words when when
is you know before numbers were invented
people would probably used I mean who
knows but but I mean the concept that
you can separate you can factor out the
number and the thing it's counting there
probably other examples woman doesn't do
that right you wouldn't say well other
examples in English couple pair anybody
know a language were there examples
other than this example in Irish yeah I
mean in in Japanese again there's a
bunch you know there's a different word
a different set of counting systems for
days of the week or bottles or pets you
know you have one two three four but if
you say I have three bottles use a
different word for the the number of
them and then you would four days of the
week or people it's the so how do we
deal with that I mean in our current
when we have integer name right if we
have integer name three comma Japanese
do we have that I thought we had that
and by the way why didn't that also
complete okay is that right yeah that's
the the general number right so I think
I think for integer name we have like
ordinal cardinal we do but but please
and switch my guess gets to be the
person again for this is let's deal with
the autocomplete there oh I see it's
equivalent to okay so we have those so
we have masculine feminine but we don't
have these much more specific things
yeah so for example it's not an integer
name but an integer string there's both
Japanese and Japanese financial because
the writing system
you know because one two three four all
just extra strokes for the financial
system you use different numbers so that
when you're writing a check sum I can't
just add a line and add a thousand
dollars to what you owe them that's an
interesting bug in the writing system
mm-hmm I didn't know that okay but so so
are you saying that the this in fact
does cover everything that's needed are
you saying that this still doesn't this
only cover is a subset of it I mean I
think I I don't know if you'd
necessarily call the counting system
used in Japanese as a different integer
name or a different integer string it
I'd have to think about it a little bit
but I can poke Allen a little bit about
some of the the work we're doing in
broadening some of these projects for is
it so that's the wait a second so that's
the string of that kind but ended your
name is the one I mean I thought you
said that that's the thing that is more
ethic because you're saying integer
string are you saying I'm now totally
confused so now in such a string in
Japanese um of 33 comma J ponies okay
and that autocompletes for some bizarre
reason is just that hmm so I don't
understand that so this is what's the
different is it the case that there's no
analog of 33 like that in Japanese not
really spelled out that way now
okay um yeah that's really like three
tens three would be can we try one other
example what what about another one of
these is that the case with HIA can you
say Hebrew for which one and two just
one or both okay so that is using sort
of the numerical okay it's displayed
backwards but that yes that's the word
four thirty and three okay great and the
integer string one is using the
numerological system where letters have
certain values okay so does anybody know
Chinese and traditional Chinese what's
the I mean what isn't that Chinese
versus simplified is that does anybody
know whether these are the the analog is
this traditional mean traditional as in
Taiwanese versus simplified as in
mainland or something different
anybody know here may be the wrong group
of people I'm guessing its traditional
is in classical and it shouldn't it be
like traditional versus simplified right
oh yes it would normally be but but
that's what but I mean unless this
meaning of traditional is something
different oh there's simplified Chinese
now I'm totally confused chinese
Simplified Chinese what's the difference
between okay let's not go down this
rathole
right now
that's the same as Japanese yeah
Japanese uses the same they use
traditional so if you do simplified
Chinese it might actually be different
it's still the same it's the same 403
interesting okay well I wonder where
they differ all right it's a question
for for Francisco yeah Francisco's group
worked on this I can yeah we'd also
somebody who speaks Chinese which we
don't happen to have in this meeting as
it happens um okay all right let's go
back um to symmetric difference um yes
so symmetrical difference we have
already discussed in the past and we are
going to implement it with this design
which follows region symmetric
difference I'm getting distracted again
because somebody's sent through the link
is wrong um collective words measure
words in Chinese all right well this is
this is a can of worms which we need to
explore but not right this moment
um okay symmetric difference yes so
symmetric difference will follow that
region symmetric difference but then
there is also boolean region which takes
an arbitrary boolean function yes
potentially various argument so I was
wondering whether it's also worth having
this I was calling it boolean region
weighted boolean Union wouldn't Union
sort yes okay so what does this do now
so boolean region shouldn't it be like
boolean list or boolean set I think it's
gonna be a weird weird name here because
I think okay so boolean region takes the
XOR so what's effectively doing is
it's taking every point in this thing
here and it's saying take the XOR of
that point being present so there's sort
of an indicator function for every point
in the space yep and every point in that
space right um and okay so the analog of
that would be combined lists by knowing
I don't understand the presence or
absence no I'm confused by what's here
yes so we would start by taking the
union of those two sets and then we
compare it we compare each one against
those two sets I see sixteen
possibilities which are actually eight
because of the symmetry and and doing
that a sex exercise we realize it's a
bit further down then we have all of the
functions except for symmetric
difference that's funny
I see so we have I see so these are so
in effect I mean intersection is and
correct union is or compliment is
probably an and of some kind is it
what's NAND it's some sort of implies I
think well then why isn't it in this
list since it is in the list of the
sixteen possibilities yes so that's what
I'm saying they're in the 16
possibilities we have all of the cases
except for number four which is
symmetric difference but that's not what
where's NAND I mean the case that would
be your boolean union of NAND right so
boolean Union there so if that boolean
function if your boolean Union here if I
say blowing the union of NAND and then
this
okay so what is that doing so that's
saying not in both of them right so
that's I think that's precisely
symmetric difference oh it is right okay
yeah right symmetric difference is
precisely the union of where eight first
- second and second - versus fair enough
okay okay so then what's nor what the
empty list yeah right so the or is the
intersection it has to be not or is
young orders Union right so it's the
negation of Union which means it should
be the complement right so it'll be the
empty set rate or so notice yes there's
always the empty set right yeah I see
because it can't undo the Union in some
sense right it's right basically it's
taking the compliment of the Union in
the Union but so one is sewers
something feels not symmetric somehow
with the use of Union here
I mean we're using Union to prepare the
data and then we're picking things out
of the data by using sort of the the
boolean ISM on those original lists but
yet the thing that we've got in the end
is a union of all those things by the
way does this work with with ternary
functions and so on as well well that
yes it does
that's if you scroll down to get that
three arguments case so there are 32
possibilities there okay so we can apply
rule 30 for example across these
different you know which is essentially
a boolean function of three arguments
right correct well if we amusing to our
boolean Union and function repository I
don't think it makes it as a I don't
think we need this I mean I
this seems obscure especially since it's
not exactly hard to implement well it's
a little tricky isn't it it's just
because it it boolean region is there I
just wanted to close the gap of the
symmetry but I I do agree that this
function is rarely needed I think it's
also quite obscure because I would claim
that in this function this does not
require pre unionization so to speak
you understand what I'm saying this
simply takes the pixels as it sees them
and does an XOR on them whereas in this
case because we've got discrete data
we've got to pre unionize to decide what
our universe says here the universe is
predefined by just all possible pixel
positions see what I'm saying well you
mean we don't have the equivalent of
their full space right I mean in this
case we don't know what the universe
what the what the universal set is we
don't have an easy way to but in this
case we do know what they might with
that name Universal set the thing that
yes yeah right um you know here there's
a natural definition of the universal
set whereas here there is not we have to
make one up by unioning the discrete
elements yes that's why Union becomes
especially important and I was having it
in the name right make sense so I claim
that we do not need a now of the boolean
region because it's less a less natural
operation because of the fact that we
have to do the Union in first okay okay
but I think it's a good function
repository thing and it sounds like the
design of symmetric difference looks
perfectly reasonable to me here well
turns the list of elements that appear
an odd number of lists is that the
natural thing to do yes it is I mean
that's what people normally do for that
right yes nothing so it's kind of weird
but yes I'm sure we want the fair ogz
case it's again it's what symmetric
regions difference does or region
symmetric differences all right fine
okay that's fine okay
um
someone is asking irrelevant questions
I'm sorry about mean and missing data
not not the right group to ask that of
there are good answers but this isn't
the right group um
boolean generalization of subset Q that
is wild it's interesting well if we are
not going to have boolean Union then we
don't even need this one right boolean
relation Q or something I mean what
would it be it would be is the thing you
are presented with in this relationship
- yeah it's interesting
okay very quickly on table while which I
have to say I'm just amazed we don't
have well I mean there are two
possibilities of taking this in the
table sense or in the wild sense well
what I mean by this is keep making the
table right or am I crazy here I mean
it's like we're making table I squared I
less than I suggest saying you have to
well I was basically going to say
exactly but yes that's right that's the
problem right what what's what is the
thing that's collected at each step with
if the truth is what's collected each
step is I squared yeah table the issue
is this is a termination condition for a
table which you can do with return okay
I mean if I say table of uh you know if
I greater than ten return right
otherwise I squared I comma 20 I believe
I will get oh my gosh that's wild right
table listen to flow control no I know
that but I thought that it had some
mechanism to do this I mean that's what
I want I want to be able to return early
and exit the table yes so this is a
version of while you seen then something
like sew-on creep yes exactly but I mean
the question is what the syntax of the
thing looks like and the point is you've
got an initiation thing I mean you've
got the table um you know you've got the
initial table iterator now the fact is I
don't think it could be
multi-dimensional and be reasonable or
am I wrong well I'm not sure it's not
clear to me how this can be
one-dimensional yet so it's hard for me
to look fine on multiple dimensions well
I think this is just while but we return
the results of each iteration it will be
like a wine list Network finally came
back um what are you saying so you're
saying so it's X we use the same design
as well but we return whatever the body
gives
except that while it's full of side
effects whereas it'd be nice to have a
local variable here I mean so this will
be the form possibly table while I
squared I up to ten I less than 10 or I
less than five or something well this is
a thing that you can compute from this
this was that quick my question before
so I I would think that test should have
to be related necessarily to the
iterator because if we do that then we
are entering the slippery road of
extending the iterator like syntax wait
a second what do you mean not related to
the iterator you mean it could be just
time of day is greater than whatever it
like while and while there's no iterator
so so why do we need to if you need an
iterator then the user has to introduce
a local variable there and control it
from the tester but this is a convenient
thing is the basic basic issue is you're
doing a table and you realize you're
trying to make a list of things but you
want to stop in making that list
somewhere you know what I'm saying yes
but investing that in the first document
you have a very complicated mathematical
operation would you somehow take into
account the result of that in the test
well I know that's a good question I
mean it so it could be I mean it will
get more obscure if you start having
things where you say hash one is the
result
- two is the veldt you know like like
map indexed and so on right and Ally on
the live stream is asking about fold
while which is a good question um so
that's that's why I read it into two
formulas first and I wanted to know with
which family it goes well I don't like
setting you know I hate the procedural
ISM of while so I mean I would like to
see something when no variable is ever
actually set so in other words the test
is something that is a local test not
some side effect test a test in the
iterator variable right so I mean so why
so one possibility is it's a three argue
I mean you may hate the extra lists but
one possibility well I suppose we can
have a special case for a flat list
right so the it's a three argument thing
and we have a right so the expression
and a list of iterators and then an
early exit test in the third argument
yeah I mean the the problem is that
table has already
I mean defined itself by having a very
exaggerators right which is okay so
there's an alternative possibility okay
decorator some kind of you know exit
early I mean that was what I was trying
to do that if that didn't work but in
the same way that that option to table
we want a do while because this iterator
can also be requested in in do with an
iterator yeah I understand so that there
could be a decorator for the iterator
so this iterator here could have a
decorator exactly could be a force at
least of four arguments and the forces
are yes right I mean it could it could
look like this it could say table I
squared I goes up to I goes from 1 to 10
in steps of 1 it's a fifth argument by
the way yes I less than five I think we
considered this about 20 years ago
although my I mean I guess my question
to you is what would be a non-trivial
test that only applies to the iterator
value that you might want to use right
that one you could just yeah that one is
silly yes right I mean the the case that
will be not silly is I cubed is less
than 600 for example
that's not silly right although right
you can do that one as rate one as one
cube root of 600
oh yeah I could happen to be able to
solve this but I can easily make this
something that I can't write and we
could do prank you're fine yeah yeah
Sandra's suggesting something about
table being able to make an association
table I think I don't understand this
quite this is I see it's it's a question
of um I mean we've already got things
like I ABC what is the analog of
association of table for associations do
we do we don't have that do we write
because you need a distinct key yet for
every oh we need it's effectively
association map right which we which
certainly does exist yeah
think that this exit criterion yeah I
mean they think Eddie I mean it's a
little clumsy having to write out the
five you know I was very it's very ugly
but I mean that could be done with some
decorator there some symbolic rapper
inside the inside the brace well I mean
actually the more natural thing to do
would be to say table I squared and then
outside of this something like um let's
see
I mean I'm this is silly but iterate
until I ten you know I to the sixth less
than three hundred that type of thing um
I know that's more typing than I know I
know I know it's a bit but it's not easy
to do this I also look there's a
particularly silly name for this
I wonder if well maybe we just want to
allow a rule right like exit or yeah
actually call it suggesting break which
I I thought one of these worked on here
I just don't know what time yeah no
break is the one that's really really
broken
well it's design it's not broken it's
just designed for very specific things
[Music]
but the cases we can look at are this
kind of procedural idea of an if break
type thing which I don't think is crazy
and might be easier to understand and
more flexible than one of these things
which decorates the iterator
I was thinking that because this
condition imposes a limit
perhaps it's such an irritation of the
third argument of the iterator because
the tank in the it's a it's starting and
then it's the this is yeah okay so fine
so that's probably where the you know
that well that could be where we
decorated okay we don't never finish
this discussion right now those one coin
from Ethan on the livestream fix we
should fix parallel functionalities fort
with issues even things like monitor of
parallel do doesn't work
humph is that right I hope I do what's
that
yeah I'm not entirely sure what that
means so that by the way is a very ugly
right right because all of the I yes all
of the eyes are in the local are in the
room right are in the slave kernels not
in the master kernel and the right the
the the kernel the master kernel has a
connection to the front end and it has a
connection to the slave kernels the
front end it does not have a direct
connection to the slave kernel so it
can't update right right so the I what
you're saying is the I inside the
parallel kernels is a separate I from
the I in the monitor correct because
that's the one in the master kernel that
is what the front end sees I mean isn't
this the horror of not having a shared
memory model right I mean we don't have
a shared memory model which has by with
the Torah but I mean if we had a shared
memory model then the I would be the
same I but then we would have all kinds
of
you know locking you know um ESU's right
well I mean this is an interesting
question how one should do this because
you know accessing the value of I in one
of the slave kernels should be possible
right so basic yeah so I guess monitor
would somehow need to specifically know
about like parallel do right say the
problem is that right I don't think
monitor has deep knowledge of the
functions right it would okay so I guess
there are two questions one is you know
monitor would need to know what are the
names of the eyes on the different slave
kernels or you know somehow access them
and the second question is and which is
more of a John folks question is can it
right can the front and then right can
we a synchronously update that value
sorry what was that but by the way I'm
reminded of something here on the from
so it's right so so if do do the monitor
with just a normal vision so I just
point out this is going to work like yes
I mean it's horribly inefficient but it
works now is it horribly inefficient
well you're creating the full list of
twenty things and then you need to
create a new list where you've through
through normal evaluation arguably the
compiler could do something clever here
yes sorry what go back to what you were
saying about right so so if you if you
remove the parallel from your that
monitor input and just do a normal do
right so there's a single eye there and
and it's being updated asynchronous
printed cell there contains a single
right that cell isn't changing it
contains a single dynamic which is being
asynchronously updated between
colonel and the front end which have the
link right the asynchronous link for
dynamics the question is can that
asynchronous link somehow connect to the
slave colonel and I have no idea that's
a that's a John Folse level question
that I have no inside and and Roman for
the whole parallel ok this is a good
question for the core software
engineering meeting maybe a Sushma could
you bring it to that meeting who is be
having that meeting now by the way dad
oh okay um okay I think we have to wrap
up here okay it's um thanks everybody
here and thanks to folks on the
livestream all the good comments much
appreciated and we will be um yeah look
forward to version 12 coming out the
beginning of next week and I look
forward to doing a live stream I think
um we may have some other live streams
on Friday I'm gone for two days here so
we won't have any fur for two days but
we probably will have something on
Friday and we'll definitely be having
some exciting stuff on Monday or Tuesday
all right good talk y'all soon